well okay let's let's get good news
good news for everybody
so you can you can have some optimism
and hope for your day
federal probe into hunter biden has
reached a critical juncture and
investigators are weighing possible
charges
so i don't know crack your beers yes
order your pizzas get your wings have a
celebration kick back
nothing's happened yet but maybe hunter
biden will actually be charged for being
a criminal do you guys think that's
actually gonna happen no no i don't
either
but it's like
sprinkling a little bit of hope in front
of us it's so nice like maybe there's
going to be some accountability i think
what would happen even if he was right i
mean everybody's seen all the i mean we
literally have video footage you know
it's kind of like that old feel better
you know it's kind of like that old joke
where they're like how would you what
would i think dave chappelle's one that
did he was like how would you agree that
it was uh r kelly actually did it i'd
have to have a video of his grandma
pointing at him going that's my baby
like there's
countless videos of him doing co doing
coke crack
weapons strippers the the weighing meth
video was like the funniest where he's
like he's arguing with the hooker about
how much meth he's got on his scale is
that math or crack i've heard both did
you ever uh i'm pretty sure it's
everything
everything a little bit of a lot do you
remember when bush's daughters like it
was a big scandal because they were like
buying alcohol
now we have like hunter biden who's like
with his hookers weighing his mess like
what a country what a time she's like
that's 20.7 he goes it's 20.6 oh okay
like she's trying to rip him off i got i
mean you gotta charge you guys you're a
negotiator do you see the was it the
babylon bee that wrote inflation is so
bad you could only buy
he has 20 you know i was like you can
only buy 2.6 grams of crack from what
used to be able to buy 28.6 or whatever
yeah i mean if you get if it gets
charged it gives me a you know i go from
having no faith in the government to
having like point one percent yeah
really will he throw his child under the
bus to
to renegotiate faith i think this must
be a crazy time to be his kids i think
one of his daughters is getting married
they're going to host her reception at
the white house like meanwhile while
she's planning that we have like her
dad's hooker and meth photos
one of hunter's daughters yeah one of
hunter's daughters is supposed to be
getting married i think i think it's one
of the biting granddaughters who's gonna
have a reception at the white house i
assume soon before he has to maybe leave
office
uh but i think it's one of hunter's
daughters and i just think like
man that's your dad do you invite dad is
he allowed to come to the wedding i
don't know definitely video chat careful
you know like if you're hunter just word
of the wise a word work word from the
wise hunter make sure your dad doesn't
sniff your daughter
does he get to bring a date is the
question
allegedly he must allegedly hunter calls
his dad appetito
really
so it's allegedly yeah yeah
leaked texts he refers to his dad as
peter peto peter
which is honestly like if you think
about it like that then you almost kind
of have to have like he almost becomes a
sympathetic figure like is he that
messed up because
you know i think joe biden abused hunter
oh for sure like how do you get a guy
raising a family that wealthy to turn
out the way he did with hookers and all
these drugs because his his dad gropes
and sniffs little kids publicly what
does he do with him in private he's
probably vacant a lot too being a
politician
working on the hill like he was always
away at work his lifts his son his son's
mom and
sister had died in the car accident when
he was like two when hunter was two he's
in the car with them so he lost his mom
he lost his sister his brother actually
died uh beau biden from cancer a while
back like a decade ago or something so
hunter i mean what a broken environment
just from a top-down observation looking
at that family yeah now then you add the
personal stuff that he actually calls
his dad allegedly peto peter you don't
just joke around about your parents
being pedophiles
i don't know people that joke around
about their parents being pedophile i've
never met somebody like that no i was
not joking yeah i thought it was weird
that during i think it was it must have
been the 2020 uh democratic national
convention that they
were highlighting all of his
granddaughters really intensely and then
all of a sudden they're like and his one
grandson they're like we talk to grandpa
every day and like we do this and like
you know i obviously hope they have a
very positive and healthy relationship
with whoever in their lives but like
they really really focused on these
girls ignoring the fact that he had two
sons they didn't really talk about any
of his actual kids it's like they needed
a fresh face because maybe everyone else
like couldn't
manage to swing a positive statement
about biden it was just weird you're
talking about
hunter's daughters or joe's so he has
like
five grandchildren i think and i think
it's uh or maybe four but it's like two
girls from beau's marriage and then a
boy and a girl from hunter's marriage
tara reid complaints where she said he
pushed her up against the wall and just
basically sexually assaulted her in one
of the cap in one of the buildings over
there on at the capitol and like the way
he grabs women and not talking about joe
biden has on video like grabbed women
and smelled them and sometimes you see
the girls recoil like that one redhead
girl was like recoiling from it i mean
very overtly like
making that face like what is he doing
kind of face and you can hear him going
like give me some of that sugar that's
so nasty it's so just i mean that hard
grab you know i mean that's like an old
1950s
her when she's like if she's if you're
angry it kind of
come on man weird life you got to give
her a firm open palm smack on the bottom
the tara reads stuff has to be
investigated i mean it was so what her
claims are so damning about what he did
to her i mean dude look at the guy
there's websites dedicated to showing
him sniffing and groping and debut just
like it's it's it's abusive to children
you know
truly literally what that girl was going
through when that red hat was that was
like a form of abuse remember when joe
biden would say
that you know i'd be at the pool and the
kids would touch my hairy legs i got
hairy legs remember that stuff yeah
someone made a meme and they said uh
what if corn pop
actually was just a dude who saw biden
creeping on children and called him out
what's the corn pop story joe biden said
he saw a guy get up on a diving board or
he's running or something he said hey
yes sir stop running and the guy was
like what did you call me and he called
her esther williams or something so the
corn pop guy you know had a hit a razor
blade you put in a rain barrel get it
all rusty you know
and then joe you know some guy told him
get a chain and fight him and then joe
said i apologize carl and yester man i
shouldn't have done that and the guy
backed off it was a story he told at the
pool and a bunch of people were like you
know what makes more sense is that
a young ish a young man joe biden
was creeping on children because he's
he's you know a creepo and this dude saw
him and was like yo get out what the you
know what i mean
i mean biden told his stories like the
kids would grab his legs
it's a creepy story anyway i got hairy
legs the kids would grab my legs and
they would rub them and the hairs would
go straight that's what he said
i think corn pop may have been like you
leave those kids alone man
shout outs corn pop shout out yeah what
if corn pop was the good guy he was the
hero we needed the twist
that's the twist
that's the twist we need i mean i think
joe biden's an abusive guy i think he's
a corrupt guy i think he's crooked
across the board and it wouldn't
surprise me if this whole sick thing is
an act so that people think he's a
bumbling idiot when he's actually just
gut in the country regarding this story
about hunter biden possible charges what
are these possible charges for
tax uh false tax violations or making
false statements when buying a gun
he would have been prohibited from
purchasing a gun because he admitted he
has a drug problem and that's what
everybody was calling out like
you you care about gun control start
with a resting hunter biden who lied in
his gun for him
we all saw it and then he threw the gun
in a dumpster no it was
his wife somebody threw it in a dumpster
throw a dumpster next to a school what
the heck
well that's always been the issue with
when people scream for gun control like
you've got you've got
gun control in place everywhere now you
just don't actually enforce it
so what's another rule what's another
law it's not going to do anything but
now that i mean i didn't know the thing
about the pedo thing i was i was
sexually abused as a kid and so like
that has a you know that has a
relatively profound effect on you for
the rest of your life and now like now
you made me feel so bad for the guy i'm
like man
lord what if he really does have all
that issue and he's just been the
scapegoat for this the whole time yeah
hunter biden was probably abused by his
dad i mean i do think though that like
people
who suffer horrible things as kids still
have some responsibility for the damage
they cause as an adult i absolutely
agree with that i'm a big person for
personal accountability
but at the same time like for me it was
like family members that did it to me
but they weren't
setting congressmen you know there's a
there's also like a level of
i don't know if you're at that position
or you're president like i've met a
couple presidents and like
it's weird like you get an it's almost
like a presence about them and so you
add on top of the fact that they're your
dad that oh yeah they're one of the most
powerful men in the country too
like what could he have got that guy to
do you know what if he was just a
scapegoat what if it was more than just
uh he was you know sexually abusing him
with the mental side of it you know what
you're going to do this you're going to
do this i'm going to actually put you
out as a pawn so if anything bad happens
it's happening to you it's not happening
to me but i'm still going to reap the
benefit of all the deals that you make
i've heard that jill and hunter also do
not get along at all jill joe's current
wife at you know his hunter's stepmom
basically now this is hypothetically
just resents hunter because not only
does he remind jill of his his mother
joe's first wife and probably love of
his life or something but like hunter's
a
a screw-up and so he's putting a bad
name out there so she's like oh and he's
hurting joe's reputation i can't you
know so but in the text he's like really
vicious against her as well which i
imagine is another layer of stress
family stress personal stress
i have sympathy for him but i don't
doesn't condone the behavior yeah i mean
i can sympathize with like victimhood
but nothing that he's done you know like
look he's an adult man who has done
really messed up things that's that's
that's that's not him it's a lot of it's
two is non-violent so that's you gotta
take that into account too like oh
possession charges you know prostitution
drug charges like no one's dying if
people have been shown up dead oh i was
talking about his illicit business
dealings with
than the coke foreign the drugs in my
opinion well maybe that's why they go
for the gun thing or this type of charge
here because we can say we convict you
on something or we can we can go that
but we're actually going to ignore the
really bad things that you did
they distract from the bigger issues and
the illicit business dealings by lock
you know get and they'll give them a
slap on the wrist it'll be like well
it's your first time and you know you're
going to get a year probation or
something yeah well they stand by
pardons them yeah well
there's a bunch of kids like there are
young children i mean they're in their
20s or teens now but like
remember that hunter had an affair with
bo like he was married and then he had
an affair with bo's widow like there are
your actions have tons of consequences
there are people who you brought into
this world who did not choose to be the
grandchild of a politician to be the the
daughters and sons of like a guy who
is you know i i want to be empathetic to
what he might be struggling with but at
the same time like
this guy
is
destructive and he takes people down
with him it seems like especially people
who don't and he really deserves it yeah
yeah he's just filming but he's really
good at weighing math so it's it's
almost like there's that uh james
o'keefe meme
where
it's it's like a guy meets a hot girl
and immediately just says to her like so
let me tell you about the all the
corporate malfeasance i'm involved in
yeah and you wonder why it is like james
gets these guys on camera like why are
you telling them about these things you
do at your job that's wrong it's so
weird
and hunter biden's like an inverse of
that where he's like i'm doing something
legal better get my camera what the heck
better film it put it on my phone than
the cloud in my laptop it feels like a
self-destructive streak like i'm trying
to get caught like i can't i keep like
i you know i want to i want to make
atonement right maybe he has a
conversation with jesus every night and
he's like i'm really messing this up so
i'm i'm trying to get what's supposed to
come to me but they just won't arrest me
no matter what i send them yeah leaving
the laptop
like he did that you could argue maybe
he was drug addled and forgot it but
that feels like self-hatred and like he
wants to take down joe and he wants to
expose it all but doesn't have the
strength feels like he can't overtly do
it so if you make it seem like it or
maybe he just knows nothing's gonna
happen to him and it's like flaunting it
in your face i'm going to do whatever i
want you can't do anything about it i'm
protected by dad and we just can call it
a day i think drug addle makes sense
but he probably walked in and he was
like
he might have forgot that he left it
there but but drugs most well actually i
don't know i can't speak for all drugs
so i don't know if he was doing crap
yeah he was probably wired
yeah i don't know he probably took that
whole computer apart and rebuilt it
himself maybe biden's kids are just very
forgetful i mean he leaves laptop ashley
leaves her diary like they just are not
good at keeping track of their
belongings yeah it's just a stutter to
record everything he just stuttered no
i'm just kidding that was a that's a joe
biden meme thanks for checking out this
clip from tim cast irl come hang out
live monday through friday at 8 pm
eastern time super chat we'll even
answer some of your questions if you
want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time